Fox News had an interesting piece
yesterday on what's going on here in
terms of people living paycheck to
paycheck and it was actually quite
shocking because apparently it's a whole
bunch of people who were even making
over 100 Grand a year 166 million
Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck the majority of people who are
making more than a hundred thousand
dollars a year say that includes them
living paycheck to paycheck retail
spending's been down in several recent
months into inventories up inflation has
outpaced wage growth for 21 months and
gas prices are up again the last five
weeks in a row okay so the the inflation
wage growth thing is the most important
inflation starts Rising that means your
money's worth less and now if you're not
making as much money that disparity
keeps continuing right you're not making
as much and the stuff is costing more
your dollar goes less far and that is
the disparity we have right now this
concept of of 51 of people making over a
hundred grand or going paycheck to
paycheck is super interesting now I
don't know that you can blame that all
on the bad economic state that the
country seems to be in I actually think
you can blame a lot of that probably on
education over the last 20 years people
don't know how to save people don't know
how to oh I have a credit card it has a
seven thousand dollar limit I only have
50 bucks in my bank I guess I could
still spend seven thousand dollars I
don't think there's basic financial
literacy in this country ironically or I
guess not ironically this is completely
the reverse of ironic we're teaching
financial literacy here in Florida
because we are the state of Competency
not the state of confounded idiocy which
is pretty much what's happening from the
national government
[Music]
thank you